[Música]
a orillas del loira leonardo da vinci
está en casa
[Música]
fue en amboage donde el artista más
famoso pidió a los últimos tres años de
su vida
[Música]
muchas personas intentan revivir este
increíble legado como estos 450
voluntarios
cada año preparar un espectáculo en el
castillo dedicado a la estancia del
genio italiano en la corte de francisco
primero
los ensayos tienen lugar en la sala de
juntas dragons monteiro dirige la
compañía
las damas dan un paso adelante 12 doy
clases de baile y no es mi trabajo en
absoluto pero transmito lo que me han
enseñado los caballeros dan un paso
adelante y cómo se puede empecé de
pequeña como un extra y luego aprendí a
bailar y 1-2-3-4 los bailes se han
grabado en un registro en francés a mi
tiempo que se está traduciendo para
recrear las danzas de la época y se
anidó en su tipo
los actores voluntarios ensayan durante
todo el invierno
si no tú te muevas
durante el verano reviven el ambiente
del castillo al ritmo de las fiestas
reales de la época de leonardo da vinci
a unos cientos de metros del castillo lo
que luce la casa del artista
esta mansión está enteramente dedicada a
la memoria del genio en particular los
favores donde el chef stefan sosa
preparan recetas típicas de renacimiento
qué va a cocinar para nosotros soy chef
bueno hoy vamos a tomar una crema de
coliflor naranja y cúrcuma lo que es una
entrada que francisco primero consumía
el chef pucha la coliflor en zumo de
naranja con una pizca de cúrcuma
su reto poner al día estas recetas
olvidadas
es en primer lugar un trabajo de
investigación personal la lectura de
indagación en todas las bibliotecas
esta es la habitación del señor de la
casa solía cenar
el chef descubrió que al final de su
vida pedía a su cocinero recetas ligeras
se trata primero de verduras de carnes
blancas y de consomé y al final de
frutas y wii
[Música]
a un paso de electrolux en la ciudad el
campanario fogones monteiro visita a las
costureras de su compañía
hola hola florencia
cómo estás estoy bien
ella está quitando todas las perlas
porque vamos a mandar a lavar estévez
vamos a lavar eso no podemos dejar las
perlas para limpiar un vestido como este
no porque es una de las perlas
[Música]
y su vecina hace lo contrario es decir
es una chaqueta que se ha limpiado y se
colocan las perlas así que ahora suponen
las perlas después de quitarse las ya
está por eso tenemos trajes bonitos
coser surgir remendar reparar
estas voluntarias confeccionan y
mantienen los cientos de trajes que se
usan durante el espectáculo en el
castillo si los habitantes de amboage
mantienen vivo el legado de leonardo da
vinci en el castillo de chambord el
investigador erigió a no no se queda
atrás
[Música]
siempre está la casa del más mínimo
rastro del maestro en los rincones del
palacio
habría inspirado da vinci este castillo
construido después de su muerte
la investigación comienza en la escalera
de la torre del homenaje
todo lo que vemos aquí en esta escalera
nos remite a los dibujos de leonardo
realizados para las escaleras que suelen
ser una especie de inventos de leonardo
no necesariamente para su ejecución y en
chambó resulta que tenemos una escalera
que no solo es doble sino que está
ubicada en el centro del edificio y se
convierte en un tipo de verdadero
espectáculo para la corte
un asombroso parecido pero eso no es
todo también habría otra pista sobre la
intervención del maestro
lo que puede ser tan característico del
arte de leonardo en la arquitectura de
chambord es en última instancia la
disposición interior del edificio
principal la torre del homenaje una
planta en forma de cruz griega compra a
sus iguales durante toda su vida
leonardo persiguió obsesivamente el
diseño de una geometría perfecta para
los edificios especialmente las iglesias
de planta central es posible que
leonardo haya diseñado el caso de
chambord la primera planta de cruz
griega para un edificio civil
entonces leonardo inspirador de chambord
conjeturas más no pruebas sin embargo la
historia no termina ahí durante la
segunda guerra mundial la moralista fue
escondida en el castillo esta importante
obra no fue devuelta a la luz hasta 1945
[Música]